la vaccination reste un grand défi mais
il ya de l'espoir du côté des
traitements qui serait prometteur contre
la maladie d'ailleurs le ms a recommandé
vendredi deux nouveaux traitements
charles vous allez nous expliquer tout
ça commençons avec le traitement à base
d'anticorps monoclonaux de quoi
s'agit-il oui en fait le médicament dont
on parle là de la part de l'om sc
lesautres ovi maps de glaxosmithkline
chaude et hino difficile à prononcer
alors on se concentre
un lot score monoclonal au fond ce sont
des anticorps qui ont été créés
artificiellement et qui sont qui cible
directement les parties du virus qu'il
faut bloquer pour que le virus ne puisse
pas s'attaquer s'attacher à la ceni
humaine on se souvient par exemple dans
le cas dans l'ensemble reid général il a
été un des premiers patients recevoir ce
cet anticorps monoclonal c'était en 1920
les cadeaux et directement en 2020 et
puis on a vu qu'en 48 heures il s'est
remis alors ses autres clubs clos ont
été utilisés au canada et au québec
continue à l'être d'une certaine façon
mais malheureusement le ried général des
hôtes de cette classe là ne sont plus
efficaces contre le micro parce que le
micron a muté mais le saut trop vie
nabeul dont on vient de parler lui il
est et il est très efficace il va
chercher jusqu'à 79 % d'efficacité
auprès des patients qui sont à haut
risque d'avoir des complications 6 intra
placo vide on parle de personnes âgées
de personnes qui ont des cours morbidité
de personnes qui sont en dialyse ou des
patients en oncologie quand un système
immunitaire qui est compromis alors ces
personnes là peuvent être traités par
par sept médicaments mais il faut que ce
soit diagnostiquée en 25 jours il faut
qu'on puisse recevoir ce traitement
rapidement c'est une infusion par
intraveineuse ça se fait sous forme
contrôler médicale en clinique ou à
l'hôpital donc
c'est prometteur mais il ya une certaine
lourdeur dans la façon de l'appliquer et
puis les médecins les hôpitaux le val
mais on attend plus de doses on en a
reçu quand même quelques milliers mais
on en veut beaucoup plus et le fabricant
va essayer de le faire évidemment le
plus preuve le plus rapidement première
percée majeure avec fight the women the
c'est une pilule alors ça c'est encore
beaucoup plus facile des pilules qu'on
peut prendre à la maison c'est un c'est
un médicament qui s'appelle pacs au vide
et il est efficace il est très
intéressant tout ça est préliminaire
bien sûr mais écoutons ces explications
de ma collègue gaël lucia berdot de
découverte qui va nous montrer comment
le pacs le vide fonctionne
[Musique]
le virus du sras sco v2 a besoin de nous
pour se reproduire
quand ils entrent dans nos cellules son
matériel génétique et retranscrit en
protéines
d'abord sous forme d'une longue chaîne
qui doit ensuite être découpé en
plusieurs morceaux le ciseau c'est une
enzyme une protéase
pour stopper le virus dans sa
progression la molécule développée par
faisons bloc l'action de cette protéase
elle empêche les protéines du virus de
se former correctement et donc de servir
à fabriquer de nouveaux virus le
traitement appelé pacs le guide comprend
aussi une deuxième molécules antivirales
habituellement utilisés contre le vih
qui ralentit l'élimination de la
première pour prolonger son action
l'essai clinique de phase ii a été menée
chez des gens qui n'étaient pas vaccinés
près de 1000 adultes âgés de 60 ans et
plus ou qui présentait au moins un
facteur de risque de complication grave
de lakovic 19 ont reçu le médicament
après avoir développé des symptômes de
la maladie et près de mille autres ont
reçu un placebo
soixante-six personnes qui ont reçu le
placebo ont dû être hospitalisés pour la
coved 19 dont 12 sont décédées alors que
huit personnes qui ont reçu le
traitement ont dû être soignés à
l'hôpital ça correspond à une réduction
du risque de 88%